man we're going in a real dark place
i've never talked about this stuff out
loud
the american entrepreneur broadcaster
tom bilyeu i'm about to ruin that
[ __ ] good mood
i tried to believe i was special and
either luck of the draw or the fact that
i really am average i would always run
into somebody better than me i was
sliding rapidly towards depression
the breakthrough for me was to accept
that i was hopelessly average and that
that was still going to allow me to be
successful i can sum up personal
responsibility in a single quote by kobe
bryant boos don't block dunks
the most insidious thing about excuses
you have a valid reason to feel like a
victim but the question is is that going
to serve you moving forward
when i reflect on how many people in our
society are feeling anxious these days
is there something we are just
fundamentally doing wrong about the way
that we're living our lives yes and what
is that i would lose respect for myself
if i didn't say this so here it goes
so without further ado
i'm stephen bartlett and this is the
diary of a ceo usa edition i hope
nobody's listening but if you are
then please keep this to yourself
[Music]
the story you tell yourself about
yourself is the single most important
thing you're going to craft
facts i was watching a compilation of
things you'd said upstairs before i came
downstairs and that really stuck out to
me because when i think about the tomb
story that i know
it's the question that i find so
repeatedly uh fascinating is how a man
went from what you told me in our last
conversation um many years ago you were
someone that was kind of counted out by
seemingly by your mother by yourself and
other people around you your current
wife's father
to this
guy that i
see as the antithesis of that
how did you ch what did or how did you
change that self story
well the how i changed that story is so
rudimentary that i wish people would
take me seriously so the only belief
that matters is that if i put energy and
effort into getting better i actually
will get better and so you can look at
anything and say okay maybe i suck at
this right now which was the key
realization for my life okay i'm i
actually am not good like my
father-in-law wasn't crazy i really
wasn't anywhere useful for his daughter
at that time my mom wasn't crazy i
really was lazy like so she was just
picking up on the fact that i was
tremendously lazy she wanted me to be
successful
but she was just looking at my behavior
and so i hadn't been misidentified
people just didn't calculate how much i
could change and that i would
so grasp on to
the ability to change as an emotional
life raft and so the the big switch was
that i decided to believe that i could
get better and once i made that decision
it aligned my behaviors with skill
acquisition and that's all life is
acquire skills
when i reflect on this idea of like
choosing your beliefs i think one of the
things that people will come to front of
mind is it's very hard to believe
something if you don't have some kind of
subjective evidence for that thing and
when i think about my own confidence or
my own personal growth a lot of it came
from some type of subjective evidence so
i didn't believe that i could speak in
front of people because i'd never done
it before and when i hear a lot of the
narrative in the self-development
community that there's some some
narrative in the self-development
community that you need to look in the
mirror in the morning and say i am great
i am a millionaire i am i've never once
done that yeah and i th this is the this
is the
the fine line i'm trying to understand
is
why is that [ __ ] because that's
someone
apparently choosing or you know
affirming that they are something i i
don't think it actually is [ __ ] it
just isn't going to get you very far so
if what you're hung up on is
you just can't ever fathom that being
true
then saying it may begin to form this
like just like it erodes this lack of
belief that it's possible
now my problem is when people think that
just saying it out loud is going to make
it come true that for sure isn't true so
your behavior is ultimately all that
matters so if you make all the right
decisions but you have like you
absolutely think that it's impossible
for you but you still do the right
things you will win
the problem is that if you believe that
it's never going to happen for you you
won't take the steps and so when you
look at how hard something is and you
get part way down that road and you're
like wow this is really hard it's making
me confront my insecurities this does
not feel good and i don't believe it's
possible anyway then why would you keep
going and the answer is you wouldn't and
so nobody does and so everybody who
believes it's impossible and encounters
the difficulties that success will
demand of everybody they stop 100 of the
time
and so
by looking at yourself in the mirror and
saying i am a millionaire i'm a genius
like all this stuff it may function as
some
eroding mechanism to those
entrenched beliefs that it's never going
to happen for you that would not work
for me because there's a part of my
brain that just screams this is [ __ ]
like you know this is [ __ ] so for me
i had to align with what do i believe to
be true about humans i needed to be i
needed to accept that i was average that
was a huge moment for me
because i tried to believe i was special
and either luck of the draw or the fact
that i really am average i've always
been around a substantial number of
people that are smarter than me or
faster than me or stronger like
literally everything every niche i tried
to find
i would always run into somebody better
than me and it was devastating like
really devastating
and
the breakthrough for me was to accept
that i was hopelessly average and that
that was still going to allow me to be
successful and so for me the
breakthrough was reading about the brain
like just brain science and
understanding brain plasticity and so
once i understood whoa like your brain
actually can change so that means that
just because i'm not good at something
today doesn't mean i can't good at it
get good at it tomorrow and so it's like
well wait a second if the average human
is actually designed to get better like
that is our fundamental design not that
i'm special not that i'm smarter than
anybody
but once i realized oh my god that is
what the the dna of the human animals
designed to do is learn and grow from
context
and so then it was just like okay word
like if you're gonna just focus on being
the learner then get your sense of pride
out of being willing to admit what
you're not good at and to sit at
somebody else's feet and learn
and all of my success is a result of
that
tremendous self-awareness
even the use of the word realization
that realization that you were pursuing
um something as opposed to something
else and you were able to kind of
separate yourself from your ego or at
least look look down on it and
understand the the role it was having on
your decision making self-awareness and
then huge humility
are these skills
yes because i didn't have them in the
beginning interesting now self-awareness
is a double-edged sword i didn't have
any when i was a kid and i didn't have
anxiety
as i have really leaned into developing
self-awareness it's actually made me
more anxious really because i'm hyper
aware of what i'm not good at what i am
good at how i'm being perceived how i
perceive myself
that things matter like this this is man
when i really try to shake this off
the thing that i keep coming back to is
life has consequences
and
building and selling a billion dollar
company
as a consequence is like they're amazing
so
getting good at something and winning
can change your life
and those things are powerful
and so it's like i realize the game i'm
playing i realized the stakes and so one
of the things that i really have to
focus on now is like
i don't value that stuff i need to be
careful not to value that stuff
that
what matters the thing that you started
this off the only thing that matters is
how you feel about yourself when you're
by yourself and all the success in the
world can't touch that
but you're constructing that in your own
mind you're constructing a value system
you are constructing beliefs now most of
the time you don't realize that you're
constructing them so they're invisible
you just see cool [ __ ] and you think wow
that's cool you don't realize that in
saying wow that's cool you just made a
value judgment you reinforce that in
your own mind and now in some subtle way
you're moving towards that and judging
yourself against whether you have that
or not so you have to keep coming back
to
what's cool is feeling good about myself
what's cool is having a dope marriage
what's cool is getting better what's
cool is sitting at somebody's feet and
learning something new so i have to
reinforce that value system because from
an evolutionary standpoint we have all
these weird things baked in already so
50 percent of you just baked in and then
50 of you is created
really subtly from the time you are a
child and you have no idea that you're
absorbing and creating these belief
systems that are governing your value
system that are governing what you think
is worthy of respect which means if you
think that the only thing worthy of
respect is tremendous success then
you'll put yourself on that wheel trying
to earn your own respect and then if you
don't get it you'll be in the dumps and
then if you do get it you're gonna
realize it didn't matter in the first
place because you have these embedded
things in your brain and here's the most
insidious you will get this more than
most
there is no amount of success big enough
that you can stand in it forever
there's no meal
big enough no feast overwhelming enough
that you never need to eat again no
drink so thirst quenching that you don't
need to drink again we get that with
like the bodily stuff no sex so great
that you don't want sex again
so why is it that we think that success
would be any different and people think
it is they think i will have reached
that right like if you read my resume it
sounds like i should just permanently be
happy right you sold a billion dollar
company you live in a really fancy house
if you've got a lot of money it doesn't
work like that none of that stuff
carries any weight with me today i have
to earn my self-respect every day
and so i have to be really careful what
i choose to value
because that will determine how i feel
about myself when i'm by myself which is
ultimately all that matters
you mentioned the anxiety that comes
with that self-awareness now what what
is because what i heard there was this
kind of expectation that you're placing
on yourself which is part of the baked
in part of tom is that the thing causing
the anxiety now anxiety is really
complex so let's start with diet the
biggest change that i've made to my
anxiety was stopping drinking
uh sugar-free monster which i love by
the way absolutely love them uh but
there's something right there's
something in them
that causes my microbiome to get out of
whack and i will feel really anxious so
i used to have generalized anxiety
disorder i couldn't even tell you why i
felt anxious i just did all the time
and finally i realized there was a
component of diet so i no longer get
generalized anxiety now i will still get
anxious if i'm dealing with something
that's really like the stakes are really
high and it really matters to me so i
have to i've had to learn meditation
that changed my life in ways that i
can't even convey so that's been really
important but it is
it and some of it is going to be just
the way that i'm wired i have i don't
have an addictive personality but i have
an obsessive mind now my obsessive mind
has led to my success because i will
think about problems all the time and so
like i'm actually a really slow thinker
but people give me all this credit
because i can talk fast but i talk fast
because i've thought about it
obsessively
for days weeks months years depending on
what thing we're talking about
but that rumination in fact i was just
talking to
a guy that does
he doesn't like the term hypnotherapy
but everybody will understand that idea
so he's really well versed in hypnosis
and he said people break into three
personality types and the personality
type that struggles the most is the
personality type that both experiences
the world incredibly emotionally
but then has an analytical mind that
ruminates on the emotions and that's
where i'm at
so i
experience the emotional
gamut of life and it's incredible i
would never want to not it's wonderful
life is is a roller coaster of um
incredible
highs and lows and meditation and my
belief system allow me to even that out
so that i never get too out of whack in
any direction
but i'll loop on ideas and if it's a
negative idea about myself i'll loop and
loop and loop and loop and loop and so
that's why i said at the beginning what
you allow yourself to repeat is really
going to determine the quality of your
life and so i have to really get good at
interrupting that so that's why
meditation is the key for me to dealing
with anxiety like as i can feel it
ratcheting up it's really my mind
ruminating on all the ways that it could
go wrong and so i have to find a way to
insert myself to break
that rehearsal of failure and instead
force myself to focus on rehearsing
success which
it's almost silly but it really does
drop my anxiety to next to nothing but i
have to really forcefully insert myself
does it always work that process there
are things that are so high in amplitude
that it's like okay this is really like
stressing me out um
but yeah it always works i've never been
more than 45 minutes away from complete
equanimity really
and that's that's going through things
that are where there's hundreds of
millions of dollars on the line it's
like really really stressful
i've experienced anxiety too and i
before i'd experienced it i think i
experienced it in my mid-20s for the
first time when my business got really
really difficult and when the stakes got
really really high i always thought it
was something that others other people
experienced i never thought it would be
something that would find me
and um
so my perspective and my
this is why i'm so compelled by the
concept because it did find me and i
couldn't believe it did i couldn't
believe it when it did because as i said
i thought it was something that some
kind of you know maybe chemical disorder
but when i reflect on how many people in
our society are feeling anxious these
days it bake pulls into question is
there something we are just
fundamentally doing wrong about the way
that we're living our lives yes
and what is that diet is the biggest
problem i think it's 100 if you were if
you said you can have what you can make
one change to somebody's life what
change would you make to lower their
anxiety
a hundred percent their diet now once
that's
regulated it doesn't mean that it goes
away i still have anxiety but when i
think i've reduced it by 70 percent
through diet alone now the remaining 30
is still a pain so you really do want to
address it and for that i've had to turn
to meditation i've had to insert myself
into my ruminating thoughts and be very
thoughtful about that i've had to adjust
my belief system so that i'm not afraid
of failure like there are a lot of
things that i've had to do to get myself
to that place
but if i could only make one change it
would be that now
living in the social media era is
amazing it's amazing man and it's given
so much and i think it's given far more
than it takes but you really have to be
careful like to give people an idea
i have had a lot of success i have a lot
of the worldly things that people want
and even i can look at somebody's house
if people saw my house and then they
hear the following statement they will
laugh but i can look at someone's house
and be like yo that's a house right
so
uh it never ends right so it's like if i
peeked out and i had the best house in
the world i'd be like yeah but elon musk
just built a rocket that can carry 300
people to mars like what have i done so
there's always some other thing so you
just you've got to be psychotically
careful about what you allow yourself to
value yourself for because i value
achievement i think it's extraordinary
i'm very glad that i have that it makes
me strive it's pushed me to be a better
version of myself
but at the same time i have to be really
careful not to let it damage my sense of
self which it will do very rapidly
and
i think every we have to agree that
there is a north star and
for
optimizing a human life and i will say
that which reduces
suffering and elevates the individual to
fulfillment those would be my two things
reduce human suffering
in yourself and others and elevate your
sense of fulfillment in yourself and
help other people do the same like that
seems to be the cocktail for the most
resilient
mental state you could hope for so that
even as life goes up and down and you
win and lose and people are born and
people die i mean we're all going to go
through just
unrelenting misery from time to time it
just is
um and the only way to
even all of that out
is to pursue those two things now once
we have that then you start optimizing
for lifestyle and beliefs and your
thought patterns and all of that stuff
i really do feel like if you removed
social media you'd remove a tremendous
amount of anxiety and obviously
everyone's context would get smaller so
the comparison
part i mean there's various reasons
front of mind reasons why i think social
media causes people to be anxious one of
them is obviously all the feedback we
get about our success our achievements
whatever and the other is um
the feedback we go searching for via
comparison
so
me looking out at the world which is now
billions of people on my phone whereas
once upon a time my human design
probably um i was probably designed to
deal with about 20 or maybe you know a
small tribe you could also optimize here
here is the brutal thing
put out a tweet like put out a hot take
but something you really believe in like
that really matters to you and you're
moved by it and you feel like you're
adding something positive to the world
like put out one of those tweets it will
not be
universally loved i've done that last
week and it was 20 pieces yep and like
in newspapers that is that is
emotionally
brutal yeah and when you realize that
man i just want to like connect i want i
want to put something rad out into the
world but then people kick you in the
face
and it makes you want to turtle up and
so it's this weird exercise of like
you have to divorce yourself from what
other people think which is powerful if
you can do it but we're the human animal
and so you can't ever i think completely
detach we are as i like to say we are
both the shout and the echo so we are
what we say do and believe but we're
also what people tell us about the
things that we say do and believe and it
matters because we're a tribe animal
so it gets real weird and then you and i
are both into web3 in a big way the only
thing i know that's going to be more
devastating to mental health than web 2
and social media is web3 but it's also
incredible and it's so life-changing
that
we have to find a way to mitigate some
of the bad but you're taking all of the
things of web 2 and putting money on top
of it and so now people are really
freaking out
why is it going to be worse web3 because
it's money you're playing with people's
money and so now it's not fun and games
anymore it's like people are
they're oftentimes investing more than
they should
in something and so
it will be bad for them because now
something that they otherwise could have
enjoyed becomes incredibly stressful
and for the creators we're gonna destroy
a lot of creators who are just like yeah
i'm not i can't this isn't fun anymore
like it was fun but
i've now taken money for this thing i
have obligations you have to be honest
about that but if
like it's not going well most people are
not gonna have
the the tools that they need to grapple
with that to work through problems to
improve to get better like it's just
going to be really hard and so when you
take the the ability for
people all over the world to
tell you what they think
and then you let them invest money
now it gets it gets crazy real fast and
we're already seeing projects implode
because the creator was maybe an artist
who's already wearing their heart on
their sleeve
and
it just doesn't work
and they're not able to deal with that
and then the project poof it goes away
and i don't think that most people had
ill intent of course there are people
that have ill intent
but i don't think most of them do but
they're just it's a business and they
don't know how to run a business
a lot of we've talked about a lot of
stress
pressure tension and all the [ __ ]
that comes with striving you said
achievement and striving is very
important what is the cocktail the the
ingredients that you now need for that
fulfillment that you described earlier
all right i actually have a uh as close
as you're to get to a conceptual math
equation here
so fulfillment is very simple for me so
and it has to do with the directives
that are embedded in your brain from an
evolutionary standpoint
so you must work hard it's embedded in
your brain to acquire skills
that matter to you that allow you to
elevate yourself and others
in service of a goal that's both
exciting and honorable
so exciting and honorable means that
you're just amped about it you dig it so
i dig storytelling just i do and i want
to help people through storytelling i do
my life circumstances have led me to
that the way that i'm hardwired i just
have an over
um an outsized response to stories and
so i'm drawn to that and because of life
experience i want to use stories to help
people so that's very exciting for me
now it's also honorable because i'm not
just looking to
make myself rich or be admired for
telling a cool story i actually want to
help people with that story and i hold
myself accountable to that so
when you have that cocktail you're
working hard to garner a set of skills
that allow you to serve not only
yourself but other people
it that's fulfillment so people can say
whatever they want and i know like if
i'm actually out there every day doing
my best to help people i'm gonna feel
good about that no i'm not gonna feel
good about people misunderstanding that
that's still gonna suck but i know it's
in my heart and so if i'm like no for
real i'm showing up no matter what
people say i really am showing up to
help people
then
that will give you the emotional
resilience that you need to see yourself
through so
fulfillment
is
it's able to withstand even moments of
unhappiness and when you have
fulfillment the thing that you believe
in that you're fighting for then it gets
easier to push through
you know whatever frustrations
difficulties the mob coming after you
whatever if you don't have that and it
was you were just trying to be famous or
get approval and it feels like the
entire world is piling on you you just
are like yeah i'm done with this
so there really has to be something
you're fighting for
you know when you do interviews and you
make content and you do that a lot right
so you're very much like me over this
side of the table when i make content
sometimes the thing that's front of mind
comes through
so if i'm if this week or that's why
before we start recording i ask you the
question what's front of mind the thing
that's front of mind tends to come
through i can't help it so if i sit here
with a guest and they are a
chef i'll end up talking about the thing
that happened like two days ago and i
can kind of i kind of get that a little
bit from you that you that one of the
things that's front of mind is like
maybe i'm totally wrong is dealing with
the external
criticism from the mob who are
questioning something that to you
came from a place of sincerity and
authenticity is that
since we started since i started being
on camera that has been front of mind
like you really have to deal with that
and when i first started so i first
stepped in front of the camera like
seven years eight years ago something
like that and i was like
i'm not sure i really
want to do this
and i wrote an article that i thought
was
it really was like
tom what is the like the the most
life-changing thing you've realized that
you could
offer as an idea to other people and
that would change their life
and i wrote this article
about how if you get hit and in fact i'm
going to light myself on fire again
because i know how people respond to
this but this is really what i wrote if
you get hit by a drunk driver it's all
your fault
and that's amazing because you could do
something about it you could do
something different next time and get a
different result now of course i no
longer use the word fault because that
just does not lead me anywhere
productive but that was the article and
people lit me on fire
and i was shocked to my core i i cannot
tell you dude when i hit publish on that
i was like oh my god people are going to
love this it's going to change so many
lives this is going to be incredible and
then
people are not loving it and so i was
like whoa okay so that was
extraordinarily eye-opening um
but because i really am trying to help
like this was
working at quest working in the inner
cities
you realize or at least my big
revelation having big brother for a kid
in the inner cities when i was much
younger and seeing what it was doing to
him and then having a thousand employees
that grew up in the inner cities and
being like oh my god like
this is your zip code
in most of the developed world whatever
the equivalent of zip code is
is the number one predictor of your
future success and so i was like there's
got to be a way to help people with that
and the conclusion i came to is it's
this set of ideas that are timeless they
have nothing to do with me but i have a
way of explaining them through
how i had to struggle with them and so
maybe i'm able to say it in a way that
certain people will hear and so between
writing between being on camera between
um
the stories that i hope to tell that i
can embed these ideas and get them
across
and it does
they're
in today's world
i've been given a gift which is social
media which is web3 which is going to
allow me to expand all of this and reach
people i never could have dreamed of
reaching before but it comes with the
the other side which is you put
something out that really is coming from
a good place and people still are not
loving it like i i my wife and i do this
show um called relationship theory
and i did i think when i say even now
re-listening to it i can't believe
that at least half of the people that
hear it are just
infuriated
and it's about like how to
you know develop a good sex relationship
with your partner i send clips to my
girlfriend oh my god and and people were
just like who the [ __ ] does this guy
think he is i'm like wow so anyway you
really do like we're we are raising a
generation of people that need to
develop incredible mental resilience
against that if you want to
be able to engage with this incredible
gift that is the web and being able to
communicate to large groups of people
but it really does require like
developing a value system and a belief
system that's going to
make you resilient to that because it
isn't easy even for me and i've spent a
lot of time building resilience and i'm
older so it's like a lot of the things
that probably would have thrown me off
in my 20s now
don't but it's a thing for sure
that article seemed just from the title
seemed to be one that centers on like
personal responsibility am i guessing
that quickly you then use the word eye
opening because i imagine what you wrote
there still to this day you believe to
be true to the core of my existence so
the word eye opening is illuminating for
me because it means that it taught you
something not about what you'd written
but about the reaction to what you'd
written and about the people reacting
what is it you've learned about why
personal responsibility is and i've seen
on this podcast like if i'm gonna be
counseled for anything it's probably
there's a number of things but my
pursuit of like
being a champion for personal
responsibility is up there mo gowda sat
here and said when he published his book
he he open sources it to 500 people and
he says he loses about i think it was 10
of people they just click off the
document when they get to the personal
responsibility part they just
seem to be inherently offended by it
why
where is the truth yeah what can be done
okay so this goes back to what we were
talking about earlier which is i just
know people are gonna uh just really
love this section
uh but i can't help myself i would lose
respect for myself if i didn't say this
stuff i could see myself one day not
being on camera anymore i can't ever see
myself saying something that i don't
believe to be true so here it goes
you have to have a belief system that is
both true and optimistic
personal responsibility is true and
wildly optimistic and it is people's
belief system and the value system that
they cobble together over a lifetime
that will lead them to reject that
and all i can say is reject it at your
own peril for the following reason
personal responsibility is about
remembering you can do something and
change
and i can sum up personal responsibility
in a single quote
by kobe bryant
boos don't block dunks
that's personal responsibility you can
get so good at something that no matter
how much people hate you the best
athletes in the world were paid
millions of dollars and trained
to stop kobe bryant from scoring and yet
he scored 81 points in a single game
so you can get so good no matter how
much people hate you no matter how much
they're training and trying to defeat
they can't
and
that is the most exciting thing in the
world to me
that wait you're saying that i can get
so good at something that at least the
vast majority of humanity can't stop me
there will always of course
unfortunately i don't i don't yet
believe that i am kobe bryant in
anything that i care about
so
but that i can get better than the vast
majority of humanity at something by
dedicating my time and energy to that
thing that is so cool that is so
liberating it's changed my life it's
given me hope it got me up off the floor
it it in every possible way it has
changed my life it is the thing that i
rely on when i'm feeling my most anxious
i'm like i can get better at this
a word and then i remember that's right
like if i put time and energy into this
i can get better so it's okay
if i'm actually not good at this if
people are coming after me and saying
you're stupid you're seeing this wrong
i'm like maybe i really am like maybe
there's really something to learn here
even with personal responsibility if
somebody shows me that taking personal
responsibility for my life is worse than
if i didn't i would change
but in every metric i have ever
encountered and including all the people
that i've introduced this idea to that
have then gone on to do something with
it it has made every single one of their
lives better to a person without
exception and so i'm just like i want
people to win so badly i'm wired to love
other people winning almost as much as i
love winning myself when i was six i
threw an easter egg contest so that my
sister would find more eggs than i did
because i knew it meant more to her and
i just was so happy to see her win
so like it just that is innate i didn't
do anything to earn that i'm not an
extra nice person just for whatever
reason i really enjoy seeing other
people win
and so dude when i'm giving these ideas
i'm like it will help you it will help
you
you like i'm already doing it my life is
already a reflection of this
and
it's true and optimistic just to bring
it all back around it is true and
optimistic and so
i hope people embrace it i know that
some people don't because they have a
value system where they're getting value
out of being in a helpless position
and that's heartbreaking because it's it
doesn't feel good at least it didn't
when i was there
i'm trying to think of the rebuttals
because i agree that having a bias to
optimism and personal responsibility has
solved can i give you the rebuttal
please so the rebuttal is that societal
energy and momentum really really matter
and that we are the shout and the echo
so even though if you
feel like you are a victim and that life
is out of your control and it's stacked
against you and there's nothing you can
do
when you are
the recipient of legitimate injustice
the world is going to rally to your side
and be like yo
you've been wronged
we celebrate you we love you we elevate
you like this is just so crazy it should
never happen to you that will feel
awesome
and so you've been embraced and there is
a lot of cultural momentum around that
now the problem is that when you're by
yourself thinking about yourself you
feel disempowered and it does not feel
good and you're in a very dark [ __ ]
place which is a big reason why i think
right now that people are
i mean suicide is like depending on the
age groups like the number one leading
cause of death like teenage boys i mean
that's nuts
so
clearly there's something going on so i
don't think people will feel good about
themselves when they're by themselves if
they adopt that value system but they
are getting huge emotional rewards from
the crowd now the crowd can't save them
again when they're by themselves but
to deny that to be embraced
for something like that feels good would
be foolish because it really does feel
good and i spent
time there feeling sorry for myself for
a long time and when somebody's like wow
that really does suck i was like yeah
man that feels good to be acknowledged
and so i get it
and i want to acknowledge it too like it
really is when people have the deck
stacked against them that really sucks
that really sucks and there are i mean
look i've spent enough time in the inner
cities there are people with the deck
stacked way hard against them
but my thing is
you can actually get out
and you how about this you can make your
life 100 times better no matter how bad
it is you can make it 100 times better
and that joy seeing people do that is
everything it's everything for them it's
everything for me as somebody who just
likes to see people win
and i don't see that same 100x
improvement on people that embrace
a different value system but it's real
and there's a lot of momentum
is that unwillingness to accept that
idea also somewhat linked to
people's own self-esteem because when we
admit personal responsibility for some
people especially those that have a
lower sort of sense of self-worth maybe
they see that as evidence of their
further evidence of their own inadequacy
i'm going to bend it more to identity so
you build your identity
and
i i have the deck stacked against me for
whatever reason
and
when that becomes your identity
and you value yourself for that like i
have the deck stacked against me and i
stand strong in the face of this and you
know i can deal with these slings and
arrows or or i fight back against them
and so i become like i'm really on a
mission to fight against this
and
all of that becomes your identity so now
you have to give up personal
responsibility to embrace that and to
fight for it
but
you get that right you get the tribe you
get the other people in that community
that feel the same
but what you've given up is really being
able to change and to acquire skills and
to become capable of more and so my
obsession is getting people to
understand skills have utility
now if skills have utility and they let
you do something better than other
people you can do things that other
people can't do that's a monetizable b
there's something hardwired in all of us
to work hard to get to gain skills that
allow us to serve the group right as a
social animal you have an imperative
buried in your brain there is no way to
escape it to contribute to the group
so if you embrace personal
responsibility you're going to get all
these other kinds of rewards because
you'll be able to accumulate skill set
you will be able to dunk and people will
not be able to stop you right like that
becomes the reality that you live in
it's super intoxicating because
going back to this idea of why it
matters to make sure that you have a
narrative that is true because when it's
true your predictive machine of a brain
can actually predict how to change the
world to what you want it to be which i
will define power as the ability to
close your eyes imagine a world better
than this open your eyes gain the skills
you need to make that world come true
that's power
and to get that power you have to
acquire skills to acquire skills you
have to take responsibility to take
responsibility you have to reject being
in the victim category even though it's
real like that's the other thing i want
people to understand the most insidious
thing about excuses is that they're so
valid
you have a valid reason to feel like a
victim you may really be being
victimized
but the question is is that going to
serve you moving forward i'm obsessed
have you read the long walk to freedom
by nelson mandela no oh my god you have
to read this book
like when i say there are few humans i
look at and go i don't think i could
ever be that amazing
holy hell he was in prison for 28 years
and he comes out and he's like no no
we're not seeking revenge that to to a
press is to give up your humanity that
was his whole thing and so he's like i
feel bad for people who oppress me
because they had to give up their
humanity to do it so i am certainly not
going to come out and be the oppressor
that would make no sense so it's what i
call the third way this is me totally he
just didn't use those words this is me
ripping his ideas off but his whole
thing was there there are three paths
before you remain the oppressed
not gonna do that become the oppressor
not going to do that the third way is to
find that way of unity and that's what
he was all about
it's the most insane story like nobody
ever earned their bona fides more than
nelson mandela by my estimation
and when he comes out and says we need
to find the third way only the path of
unity makes any sense and like just
brought people together and refused to
to be in that victim category was like
nope like what happened happened and now
we build from here oh man that's just
like it gives me the chills every time i
think about it so anyway that's
intoxicating to me i am so into that but
i recognize the cultural momentum on the
other side and so i know how people end
up getting just enough out of that that
they stay there
quick one one of the greatest tips i can
give any small business owner listening
right now is to take risks in fact the
biggest risk to your business will be
taking two fewer risks complacency and
comfort seeking will harm your success
but taking risks can be incredibly
daunting that's why i've partnered with
vodafone business and their vhub which
offers free one-to-one sessions with
v-hub digital advisors and you can call
up and speak to one completely free of
charge sharing your ideas and getting
input from someone who's knowledgeable
on the topic and able to help you
towards your next business step to find
out more search v-hub by vodafone and
thank you for vodafone for sponsoring
this podcast
as you might know crafted or one of the
sponsors of this podcast and crafted are
a jewellery brand and they make really
meaningful pieces of jewellery and this
piece by crafted when i put it on for me
it represents courage it represents
ambition it represents being calm and
loving and respectful and nurturing
while also being the antithesis of that
seemingly the antithesis of that which
is um sometimes a little bit aggressive
with my goals and determined and
courageous and brave the really
wonderful thing about crafty jewelry is
it's super affordable it looks amazing
the pieces hold tremendous meaning and
they are really well made
there's two points i want to make i'm
going to make them at the same time the
second one's a question the first the
other rebuttal that i think i've heard
before on the topic of personal
responsibility is well steve tom you've
got a privilege of your mindset thank
you i'm white so it's really bad for me
and i'm a guy but even your people would
look at the time they see before them
today the guy that understands these
ideas that has that ability to think
through things slowly as you said but
speak about them very quickly there
seems to be if i'm looking at 45 year
old tom today a huge amount of mindset
privilege that's how it seems i'm not
saying that is i know
your
prior story very very clearly so people
say there's this mindset privilege where
it's not easy just to get up off the
floor and just learn a skill
so when i hear this article when i see
this article about it being my fault
i wish it i wish it was so easy tom i've
got chronic
deep depression the doctors have told me
there's a cycle and a balance in my
brain of a chemical
i i'm at the point of wanting to end my
life so this article it just makes me
feel inadequate it makes me feel like
it's my fault that's what i i saw i read
i felt
that's that's the thing where i go
what do we say to those that group
really yeah it's all true
and if you have a neurochemical
imbalance that really sucks like i can
just tell you looking at my mom i'm
prone to anxiety so there is um
i'm sure if when this all gets mapped
out it will become clear that i have
markers for anxiety whether they were
epigenetic or genetic but that i came
out just primed to become anxious
so that sucks for me because i've really
had to contend with anxiety like this is
one of the biggest issues in my life i
think about anxiety almost every day so
it is really a thing that i've had to
manage especially for somebody striving
in the way that i have so i'm constantly
putting myself in the position of being
anxious i remember in high school
i promised myself i would never again do
anything that made me nervous that was
the word i used back then that i would
never again do it and yet my adult life
has been a betrayal of that promise that
i made to myself in high school because
all i do is put myself in situations
that make me anxious
so
but the striving and getting better has
been a reward of untold proportions
so
when i think about
we all in some way we all have it worse
than somebody else right so somebody
with tourette's that sucks i would not
want to have tourette's somebody that
gets multiple
sclerosis that sex would not want that
alzheimer's cancer heart disease
whatever the thing is that makes your
life worse
it really does make it worse
but the only thing that compounds that
problem is to lean into that that it
sucks to be me whereas take stephen
hawking right
what are you gonna say what what
advantage did he have right like he
literally couldn't move
so in his early twenties he starts
losing every function that he has other
than his brain and he realizes at one
point
this sucks
but if i in fact he has a quote oh god
people are really gonna hate this
stephen hawking okay quadriplegic
in a wheelchair basically can blow in a
straw and move
his eyes
i think towards the end like he could
only move one eye i mean it was crazy so
this guy there's just not a lot he can
do he's been spoon-fed since he was like
30 years old like crazy crazy imagine
not being able to like go to the
bathroom by yourself
forever like every time crazy so this
guy says what i have found is that no
one will help you if you don't help
yourself
and it just is man we look at somebody
who who despite all of that is like
trying to make contributions to physics
or that you know ended up being his
stick
and he just realized that i can actually
get help from people but not if i'm not
helping myself first it's just something
that we respond to
are you optimistic you talked about this
cultural movement i'm freakishly
optimistic but because i need a belief
system that is both true and optimistic
i don't want to fall for traps and if i
paint myself a falsely optimistic view
of what's real i'll get tripped up
and so optimistic about that personal
responsibility movement everything
are you optimistic that oh that that
will gain momentum that that it will um
lose momentum
it has lost so much momentum just in my
lifetime
that
the pendulum is swinging so hard in that
direction so i don't know if it swings
back in the next five years the next 50
years it will swing back but if now
we're going to really derail but i
remember as a 16 year old boy
reading about roman orgies and i was so
angry
because i was like
how is it possible that they were having
orgies 2 000 years ago and me now in
like the mid-90s like my mom would have
a seizure i wasn't allowed to go see the
movie basic instinct
so it's like i was like how did we go in
my six-month brain how did we go
backwards i was like i feel betrayed by
all the generations between roman orgies
and now i was like how did we end up
here
it's cyclical everything is cyclical and
so once you understand the cycles
one it can be a little
daunting so if you read ray dalio's book
principles for dealing with the changing
world order
no oh it's gonna [ __ ] up your sleep so
you're welcome thank you but he uh he
outlines he goes back he goes back i
think to like 500 bce but he really
focuses on the last 500 years and he
shows you this is all a loop and that
there are only so many personality types
and you can just watch culture loop and
loop and loop and loop and cultures
build up and then they crash down the
next one builds up and then it crashes
down he's like it's freakishly
predictable it goes in six steps the
cycle does and there is not yet a
society in the last 2 500 years that has
avoided this cycle that lasts about 100
to 150 years so
the reality is that i'm like
i don't think we get out of this
cultural momentum quickly i think that
the phrase
tough men make good times good times
make weak men weak men make hard times
hard times make strong men and you loop
and loop and loop and loop and we have
been in good times for a long time
and so i think we've
i'm just gonna keep
doing my self-damage here i think we've
gotten soft
and i think because of that we are
headed for hard times and i think the
hard times will
take care of any of the um
values and belief systems that aren't
useful in the acquisition of skills
what do those hard times look like in
your oh jesus so this is fun
this i'm sure will be the last time that
i go on a podcast uh so just had ray
dalio on my podcast and in his book he
pegged civil war in the u.s at a 30
chance
that book came out i think two months
ago he now pays our chances at 40
so we're moving in the wrong direction
remember this is the guy that spent
inordinate amounts of money
researching um the movements of these
societies and
he's just like we as the american empire
we are
uh in
mid to late stage five and stage six is
civil war and revolution
so i think we're probably look here's
part of why i love web 3. i think web 3
is the only thing i can see on the
horizon that gives us a shot of bringing
back a thriving middle class which is
precisely what you need to do to avoid a
bloody civil war or revolution so that's
part of the reason that i'm so gung-ho
about it
i try not to be delusional but it it
gives me reason for optimism
but i think we are headed in the wrong
direction i think that we are getting
more and more divisive and i think every
single person has to say to themselves i
have to race to the middle
and right now people are racing to the
extremes and they want to
dehumanize the other side and look there
are things like on the personal
responsibility side i'm not angry with
people that are angry with me i'm like i
need to find a way to like meet you in
the middle so that like we can both
learn from each other and we can have
love for each other and ultimately it's
the friction between the two sides and
that not everybody should come over to
my side because maybe it's too um it's
too harsh and it doesn't show enough
empathy for people word like hey i'm
down to like come to that middle but i
need you to come to the middle right and
so what ends up happening like you can
look at these charts that show whatever
candidate presidential candidate in the
u.s is cl whatever party excuse me
whatever party is closest to the middle
becomes the party that wins the election
but as you look at the graphs they're
just moving farther and farther to the
extremes and so
while the one that is closest to the
middle will win they're still both in
the extremes
so i'm just like yo i refuse to take a
political identity that [ __ ] scares me i
think people are just putting themselves
in a gnarly position i'm over here
channeling um
long walk to freedom like as quickly as
i can trying to think just like unity
unity unity getting people together like
yay like as pollyanna as i can make it
sound like we just have to
recognize
that there are two
predominant
personality types those that are more on
the personal responsibility side and
those that are more on the empathy side
and that we need both
and we have to value each other and
i remember so i've been in business
relationships in the past not to doxx
anybody but where
i had partners that they just would butt
heads and make fun of each other all the
time and just like the other person's a
dumbass
and i was like what are you talking
about like you're both extraordinary and
so i kept trying to get them to see it
is the friction between you that makes
this magical and so stop trying to
convince the other person try to meet in
the middle with respect try to
understand where the other person's
coming from value their opinion so my
wife and i are we're alike in a lot of
ways but in sort of a fundamental
disposition we're very different and so
we talk about that all the time i value
that you see this differently than me
and hopefully you value that i see this
differently than you and let's use that
friction to navigate a more intelligent
path forward
so yeah uh to go back to your initial
question i worry
that we are headed towards either a
civil war or a war with china or both
and that if china's smart they're
watching us going yep they're maximally
divided
that man we're going in a real dark
place i've never talked about this stuff
out loud uh on camera and uh i think
that the war in russia is going to
create a
food shortage
watch the all-in podcast because these
are just crib notes
and so as they were talking about in the
recent episode basically that the food
shortage will be backstopped by china
china will exchange that for military
bases etc we're going to continue to
fight in america over dumb [ __ ] that
hardcore people should not be fighting
over that we should be
resilient and coming together and you
know loving uh
our differences and all of that stuff
and we won't be so we'll be pulling in
opposite directions china will be
getting stronger
in the world stage
and in our moment of maximal weakness
they make a move for taiwan and we have
a choice to make where we either back
down and then we effectively forfeit our
leadership status in the world which
will almost certainly mark the end of
the dollar as the the global reserve
currency which will be devastating
um or we fight and now we're in a hot
war with china
either of those options suck
so how do we find a diplomatic solution
that is my obsession and that brings me
back to web three with just pollyanna uh
ideas abounding but i i am optimistic
through all of that you asked me what
the bad thing looked like my hope is
that we avoid it
but that is the thing that i worry about
that's my disaster scenario
you're someone that's thought that
through and i'm not surprised that
you've thought that through in
tremendous detail and it's something
that's been you know another thing
that's been front of mind for you so
knowing
with my presumption that i know the kind
of guy you are i imagine you've also
thought about the role you can play in
stopping that scenario playing out
especially because you're a guy with
great resource with great intellect with
great intelligence with a great with a
great skill set with a great platform to
tell stories one that you're building
the last conversation we had some four
years ago you talked to me about this
idea of building almost a more modern
version of disney
with your with your content studios and
storytelling so what is the role that
tom thinks he can play in
yeah man uh my hope is i can contribute
i certainly don't think that um i don't
have the intelligence or the temperament
to be a world leader so i will just tell
you right now that that is entirely off
the table for me i have zero interest
um
i don't think i'd be good at it either
so let me be very clear this is not me
thinking well i'd be amazing but i just
don't want to do it i would be terrible
uh so yeah i'm definitely not going to
contribute in that way so my way
to give you one glimmer i wrote a comic
book with steve aoki called neon future
which is entirely about nelson mandela's
third way
and it plays out in a fictional way
between people that have augmented their
body with technology and people that
haven't but it was me in a comic book
exploring those ideas that trying to
point out so you have this guy keita
soviet uh who
is representing the third way he has
every reason to be angry to strike back
to
kill and yet his only thought is of
sacrifice and bringing people together
and but he's also tough and he's a
badass and he's not a pushover and
that whole idea of the meek shall
inherit the earth and meek being defined
as
the most dangerous person on earth who
keeps their sword sheathed
um you hear bruce lee talk about this a
lot sun tzu you know the whole thing is
to be so
dominant that nobody wants to fight you
so
and in that you can actually choose
peace instead of peace sort of being
just because you're too weak to fight
um
so my hope is through story i can tell
ideas that make people value differences
that make them want to meet in the
middle that make them want to love and
be loved
and to
of course adopt personal responsibility
with a plum
and recognize that they can get better
and that nobody can stop them
and that the world desperately wants for
them to
come alive and to
acquire skills that matter to them and
build things that matter to them and
unify and create incredible things
as a percentage what do you think the
chances are that that future of the us
the global sort of western power getting
into a conflict or getting into a
scenario that is potentially apocalyptic
with a russia or a china
the exact scenario you described
do you think that's more likely to
happen than not i think it's less likely
to happen as of today right i am too
ignorant on the subject to give you
anything other than to parrot people who
are far more educated on the topic than
i want to be very clear i know my lane
yeah and so i have formulated a
hypothesis based on other people's
research i have not done the research
myself i would never want to be on
national television asked about foreign
policy like be the worst person in the
world but ray dalio's
assessment of the situation
is so
astonishingly well researched
and he's been in the thick of it for
decades he spent hundreds of millions of
dollars just on research of global
trends and movements and so when he says
that he pegs u.s civil war at about 40
percent
and uh a u.s china conflict at about 40
i just trust it
so but that that is literally me blindly
parroting
quick one we bring in eight people a
month to watch these conversations live
here in the studio when we're here in
the uk and when we're in la if you want
to be one of those people all you've got
to do is hit subscribe
i like a more light-hearted topic you
said earlier about lisa and one of the
things you said is that you
fundamentally have differences
at a fundamental level right um me and
my partner have fundamental differences
and as i said earlier with your
um the content you put you put out
together about relationships and love
have been really profound and important
to my relationship with my girlfriend
and that's why we frequently send each
other the clips i've had my some of my
best friends in fact send me the clips
to because you make sense of things
together from both perspectives the male
perspective and the female perspective
in a way that's quite liberating as
someone that's going through those
things
um central to having differences which
me and my girlfriend discovered we had
is communication something that i think
you listed as like number one or two on
your list of nine things to sustain a
17-year marriage and the
whiteboard list that you and lisa held
up that time and
you said obsessively communicate that's
what you said um
what how does one of the things that i i
definitely struggled with and i want
your advice on is
what are the principles of that healthy
communication that ego free
communication that you and lisa have
adopted
never lie
okay which would make your life in the
moment temporarily easier i can't tell
you the number of arguments that we'll
be in and she'll give me an out
where she's restating my thesis a little
bit wrong but it would end the argument
and all i have to do is say
thank you so much that means so much to
me that you understand that and i'm like
that's not quite it and i know that when
i restate what it really is it's another
hour or two of arguing but you got to do
it because then you can actually get to
this is where i'm at help me understand
where you're at and then let's find the
way forward but if you never here here's
the the big problem most people do not
take the time to articulate to
themselves what's bothering them so my
whole thing and and this drives my wife
up a wall when we're in an argument she
likes it the rest of the time but say in
a single sentence what's bothering you
most people can't do it and i'll stop
her you're waffling stop say it in a
single sentence because you don't
understand it well enough and therefore
we can't get to it and so she holds me
accountable to the same thing if i'm all
over the place then she's like hey
single sentence give it to me so i can
actually understand where you're at most
people they can't they can't get to a
single sentence or they
don't want to get to a single sentence
they want to like but it's all of these
crazy things it's like it's impossible
to deal with so give me a single
sentence summation of what your problem
is no commas no parentheticals no
run-ons a single sentence i'm
feeling insecure because you
uh didn't pay attention to me when i
asked you if you wanted to go on a date
this weekend
word
now i know right where you're at but if
you don't want to acknowledge that that
made you feel insecure now we're arguing
about the tea as my wife and i call it
the biggest argument my wife and i ever
got in ever was over a cup of tea we
were screaming we were on our way to a
wonderful vacation i actually turned the
car around and was like we're not even
going we're going home right now and
literally when i turned around i was
like
this is over a cup of tea i'm like there
is no way that we are arguing about a
cup of tea to the point where i am
turning around and we're not going on
the only vacation that we've taken and
whatever at that point it had been like
18 months
so i'm like
what's this really about
and so then we got to the real issue and
i realized oh my god in communication
you have to admit your flaws your
insecurities like you need to
immediately go okay i'm angry and i know
that when i'm angry it's because i'm
insecure what am i insecure about oh i'm
insecure about this oh my god and then
you just own it here's what's really
going on for me
and now you can process through and get
to where you really want to be but most
people assume they're angry because the
other person is wrong
and once you assume you're angry because
the other person is wrong you're never
going to get to the real issue and so
lisa and i are very good about okay
what's really bothering you and then you
and of course when you're in it it just
really does feel like they're just wrong
and so i'm i'm mad because they're wrong
but
uh i have a just belief system that you
end up getting triggered because you're
insecure and so we have to figure out
what was the insecurity that got
triggered so we can address that and
figure out the path forward so
interesting i was thinking of so many
times where i waffled for the first hour
of a conversation slash argument with my
girlfriend and then an hour and thirty
in i'm able to crystallize it as
something that i i remember was in peru
with her maybe a month ago and we're
arguing about i don't even know what but
an hour and a half in i crystallized it
to a single thing which reflected an
insecurity i had from my childhood
and then one it's so funny because when
i said that target you know what it is
when i grew up with my mom and dad
and i explained it to her the argument
completely done
it was like she finally
understood
and
yeah there's something about dropping
your guard in such a way and kind of
holding up the mirror to yourself that
pacifies and shows you've arrived at a
place of honesty and not seeking victory
word that's so sweet you gave me the
chills that's spot on
one of the things that lewis howe sat
here and a good friend of yours on mine
he said when he was um talking to me
about relationships is that he met his
new partner martha and he said to us
straight up
you won't be my first priority and he
listed the things that would be his
priority so he said my mission my vision
whatever else it was and then the third
thing was like
our relationship
now when i looked at that whiteboard
that you did with lisa
number seven i believe no number nine i
believe was
this marriage is our first priority
it says yeah on the nine lessons we
learned over 17 years of marriage the
number one
the number nine thing on that list was
make your marriage your highest priority
and that sits in conflict with what
lewis said to me so i'm like
he's telling the truth is it both is it
well so it it will be a question of
results so
louis you know i love you brother uh
so i will just say this that he was
honest with her
is amazing and that's going to buy them
several years of like he told me i
understand
but i believe relationships require too
many sacrifices for them not to be the
thing that you reinforce as your highest
priority and if it isn't giving you
more than anything else gives you then
it will always lose out and so
ultimately they will
either be living parallel lives anybody
that chooses this you'll end up living
parallel lives where you each have
something that's more important
like kids which is one of the reasons
that lisa and i didn't have kids because
we were both honest like the kid would
be our first priority which means that
each of us would fall into second place
and did we want to do that and so that
was part of why we didn't have kids and
i think that's right i think that if
you're going to raise kids yo they need
to be your first priority
but i don't have kids so whatever there
are probably people that have way better
advice than me on children but anyway
that was part of why we didn't have kids
and a relationship is
massive compromise massive that's so
interesting because he said the opposite
oh no no no he said don't compromise
anything you it won't it won't anybody
who takes sex i want to make this about
lewis so dearly no and it's just
different perspectives right yeah i i
will say that uh
i've got a 20-year marriage uh to back
up my my thesis here
um and if
a relationship is compromised because
you have two people that view the world
in even slightly different ways that
want slightly different things and so
i mean louis has made it clear that
there are two things that are more
important so there's going to be
constant collision and friction there
i think we have an innate desire as a
human being to be somebody's number one
priority and i have found in my own life
that there is nothing more extraordinary
nothing more uplifting no high higher
than being somebody's number one
that is your number one and you love and
respect each other and you have a
thriving sexual relationship and
it is
it is the most profoundly joyful thing
i've ever experienced in my life it's
stabilizing so the people that have the
strongest home life take the biggest
risks
i remember when i heard that i was like
whoa that really makes sense to me
because i will say
what i say to myself all the time is hey
i'm building this thing i'm really
putting myself out on a limb trying to
build this company if it all goes to
nothing and the whole world thinks i'm a
[ __ ] at least i have my wife
and
i'm just like oh yeah word like i will
have my wife like no matter what other
people think if i continue to honor her
and the way that i honor her now
i will have my wife and so the only
thing i fear i don't fear going broke i
don't fear losing my business i fear
losing my wife because the outsized
return that i've gotten out of this
marriage compared to what money's
brought me or
um whatever micro fame that i have like
it it's awesome money is awesome the
micro fame is awesome but it's nothing
compared to my wife nothing nothing
so i mean it's just oh my god it's
incredible man it's incredible and so
that
to get that requires sacrifice it
requires attention it requires making
your first priority because otherwise
there's going to be a moment where one
person needs that and they realize that
they're giving that up right and
the thing is though from anybody's
perspective if you'd asked me at the
like when we were first dating i would
have said the same thing there's no way
we just got together you know what i
mean so you're not going to be my number
one priority so for me there was a line
in the sand when i decided to propose
that was a very difficult thing for me
i really thought about it man i debated
it is she really the one
and finally i was like well i'm either
never getting married or i'm marrying
this woman because i have never felt
like this like that she feels worth the
sacrifices all that and once i proposed
there i never once thought about it
again there was no cold feet there was
never like oh [ __ ] i shouldn't i
once i made that decision it was
everything so my advice to anybody in
that situation is there should be a line
where you say and now
because of what i want this relationship
to become
i'm going to make it my number one now
look i've built extraordinary businesses
even with my wife being my number one
priority and she isn't the thing that i
allocate the most time to and that's
important to understand but she's my
number one priority so if ever she came
to me and said hey i really need you
right now but there was something really
important going on in the business be
like word totally unconflicted awesome
what do you need i'm here which has
happened many times
so
on that it's actually nice to jaco
willing's point of discipline equals
freedom
um knowing that she's my number one that
i don't need to be conflicted if ever
those two any two things collide
it's always lisa there's like a piece in
that
is there anything you wouldn't
compromise so i once told lisa i said
look i'll give up virtually anything for
you but don't ever ask me to give up my
ambition
because i don't know who i am without it
and i don't know that i want to and look
i'm very thoughtful about in my back
pocket i keep buddhist style detachment
so that if ever i got overwhelmed it
wasn't fun anymore whatever i would just
pull out the detachment and i know how
to do that and i know how to not um
strive i know how to loosen my bonds to
desire and wanting which is by the way
something very wise for everybody to get
those tools in place especially if
you're a striver
but i love it
i love the pursuit i don't need the wins
the pursuit makes me feel alive and
business is the only game i found that
you can play until you die and so
there's something really awesome about
striving to be the best even though i
don't know i've in all of my years in in
46 years you were very kind to lowball
my age
uh in 46 years i have
never found myself to be the best at
anything and yet the pursuit of being
the best has been one of the most
thrilling rides in my life
it comes with
the cost right which is for you have
been the most severe cause that you i've
heard you name is
living with that anxiety that feeling of
anxiety was there a place that you went
to because for me when i went to when i
go to bali my girlfriend lives there at
the moment when i go there
and i'm out of the business driving
ambition
social media all the time mindset
there is a different level of peace
within me so sometimes my brain goes
well steve if you know that there's
another place you could live without
feelings of anxiety or whatever why
don't you just go live there and strive
in a smaller way outside of social media
and huge public scrutiny yeah
i'm presuming there's a place where you
felt [ __ ] there's no anxiety when i'm in
this zone yeah and i think the right
answer is i ask myself a slightly
different variation of that same
question
and it goes like this
do i still want to strive enough to make
it worth not going and doing that
peaceful stress-free life which for me
would be writing just rightful time i
have enough money i never need to work
again ever not a single day in my life
so every day that i choose to go to
battle i'm choosing to go to battle and
so the second that the answer is
no i actually it isn't worth it anymore
then i would go do that and i was just
right and knowing that i have that in my
back pocket
is
extremely
liberating so i know at any time i can
stop i can detach i cannot continue to
pursue this and that has allowed me it's
like this magic trick that allows me to
carry a lot more weight to deal with a
lot more stress because i know
every day is a choice
and so that allows me to have fun it
allows me to remain playful it it is
like when i think about
how much stress i've taken on in my life
with business i wouldn't have been able
to do it if i couldn't imagine a life
that would be just as awesome
and so there's a parallel life where i'm
a writer and i chill and spend time with
my wife and
you know whatever learn languages and
just [ __ ] travel around whatever like
that'd be awesome i would love that so
um
i just love this one a little bit more
but if i if this diminished in its joy
i've got this other thing that would be
so dope so yeah i don't have any sort of
like oh my god what would i do and i
remember so i've proven this stuff to
myself and look never teach something
that you isn't like you're not living it
that every word out of my mouth i live
and
i
realized that i could very easily just
detach myself from the success the
achievement the whatever
because when we left quest
it was like oh
just done and it wasn't hard for me in
the slightest like lisa really was part
of her identity so for her having been a
founding member of quest like it was
hard like in fact i still think she sees
it as like her child whereas like people
will almost remind me oh yeah that's
right [ __ ] i did build quest
i don't think about it it's not a part
of my identity
it's just not my brain isn't wired that
way i don't um
i don't cling on to things like that so
for me it's like
i want to feel good about myself when
i'm by myself
i want to have fulfillment and i want to
do things that i love in and of
themselves
and because and and this is the one
thing that haunts me in fact this like i
say this and i think people think i'm
kidding but i actually worry about this
in myself so i have one thing in me that
is
problematic it's the very thing i have
to struggle against in business like i'm
constantly having to course correct when
people hear me teach the opposite of
this is because it's the lesson that i
need to constantly remind myself
i really believe you can do anything you
set your mind to
but not everything
and that really bothers me and i'm not
sure why but
i have something in the way that i view
the world my belief system my value
system
uh the natural rewards that i get for
um
like even in this podcast we've covered
a lot of weird things
and
i can talk pretty deeply about a lot of
different topics
because i love that [ __ ] i want to be
able to go deep on a lot of different
things i don't want to do just one thing
and so that is the the one thing that
haunts me is i
i can
i could give something up and go do
something else very easily my identity
is not tied to this that or the other um
but i want to do everything i want to do
why
the question i get asked the most is tom
how do you find your passion
and i walk people through the process
you don't find it you build it
now one thing that i've
i worry about is because all of our
minds are different and because there's
a region of the brain that i just
recently learned about for determination
where they can hit you with transcranial
magnetic stimulation
hit the region of your brain that deals
with
determination and you'll be like i can
do it i know i can do it what can you do
i don't know i just know i can do it so
they can actually trigger this sense of
like i won't stop i'm gonna do it but
you have no idea what it is that you're
not gonna stop doing
so there's all these weird things so
anyway there's a region in your brain
for motivation which only reinforced
this idea in my head that maybe i'm just
really good at building desire
and so over my life i r one i react to
things very strongly and then when i
like something i pour myself into it and
i remind myself how much i like it i
tell other people how much i like it and
i do it in this embodied way where i get
really excited
and so i've reinforced all these things
in my mind that i really like like i
really like japan man i really like
anime i really like manga i really want
to make like those essay anime videos
that people do and like get into some
really obscure anime and i want to watch
every anime on netflix and like write
books about that [ __ ] and write books
about why as a storytelling format it's
just different man like i'm obsessed but
i also want to learn greek
that'll be dope learning greek like with
my wife i'm super passionate about that
at one point we were going to move to
greece i was going to learn i promised
myself at one point i would get
published in greek like this whole thing
i also want to write a book this mindset
stuff man it's really like a big thing
for me but by the way nothing gets me
like storytelling so i really want to
tell my stories but i also like video
games so it's like
yo
so all of these things speak to me at a
level that's like screaming passion
where i am
passionate i could live an entire life
where i was an anime scholar i didn't
discover anime until i was in my 40s but
now i could i'm not kidding i could
become an anime scholar and live an
extraordinarily joyful life
so
i have to be really thoughtful and
people that
take my course uh hear me say this a lot
you're standing in a room with a
thousand doors your job is to close 999
of them the problem isn't finding a door
to walk through it's shutting the doors
and only walking through one
that's the hard part and so my life has
been a never-ending series of
frustrations that i can only really
excel at one thing at a time
but it's not confusing to me that every
10 years i've completely reinvented
myself
wow
it's remarkable you you have an ability
to focus and achieve great things while
still being having that kind of
predisposition as you describe it to be
obsessively deeply interested in so many
things at the same time to that extent
but it shows tom it shows in your deep
understanding as you as you said of of
topics i feel like i could ask you about
anything and i feel like you would that
isn't true but i could tell you the
things that i don't know i'd be like i
don't know [ __ ] about it
yeah but yeah
we have a closing tradition on this
podcast let's do it where the previous
guest writes a question for the next
guest
tell a specific story of someone in your
life who helped make you into the person
you are today what did they do
specifically that made you into the
person you are
that's a great one
okay so
i will preface the story of how she did
it with
my one of my favorite stories about my
wife so
long before my wife became an
entrepreneur she had um
she had really influenced me in like a
jerry maguire way where it was like she
believed in me when nobody else believed
in me even when i was struggling to
believe in myself like she just had an
irrational belief in myself
in in me and
i often think back to who would i have
become if i hadn't met her because i was
in a dark place i didn't have like it's
not like i had all the beliefs that i
had now i didn't have any of these
beliefs i thought i was not smart enough
i did not think i could accomplish
and so my wife in many ways manipulated
me in these wonderful ways to get me to
see what she saw
and
it was empowering and it made me yeah
yeah like i really can't do this and it
really is that moment of jerry maguire
where he's like yeah this is good like
keep coming like she would just do that
at these critical junctures in my life
and so long before she became an
entrepreneur i
i don't remember what happened
but i was weeping man i'm not a crier
i i was like ugly crying like having a
hard time catching my breath
and i was like
you're never going to get enough credit
for how you've shaped me that i wouldn't
be who i am if it wasn't for you
and remember i found my wife when i was
24
so i went on one date with her and never
looked back she's the only woman i've
ever said i love you to in a romantic
way as my mom likes to remind me
uh and
she really really shaped my brain she
shaped my beliefs she shaped my
motivations like you know a woman to
whom you are sexually attracted there's
almost no end if she's got like real
emotional wisdom there's almost no end
to which she can motivate and encourage
and
um
yeah shape you like she's just
she's my best friend she's my lover and
with that she has all of the the levers
at her disposal to help me maximize my
potential
and she has
openly pulled those levers and made me
believe and encouraged me and supported
me oh my god and so just like all of
these things and so one day somebody
asked me like who's had the biggest
influence on your life and i was like my
wife like that's just so self-evident
it's the one you could remove anybody
else from my life even my mom and i know
she doesn't want to hear that
and i would fundamentally be
similar to who i am
wouldn't be the same my mom obviously
had tremendous influence on me
but
i would not be
anything like what i am if i hadn't been
married to lisa like it's just crazy
it's crazy the thousands of little ways
little moments where she's in my head
like you know encouraging me or making
me question a decision making me think
smarter about something i'm just crazy
so
she loved the idea of behind every great
man is a great woman
and she was just
so adept
at like go ask for this
go talk to this person
push on that
and i was like i don't know like that
makes me feel uncomfortable she's like
no no trust me you've earned it
you're worth it
push for it
and i would push for it and get it and
be like what the hell so it was it was
just extraordinary and so yeah that was
a very long answer to that question but
lisa
a beautiful answer very inspiring and um
so much truth in that for so many people
that are listening and i and i do hope
you know when we part of the reason we
have podcasts and we have these deep
conversations that are full of context
is so that people can
understand intention they can have
conversations that aren't always
comfortable or that that don't fit in
280 characters and that aren't meant to
fit in 280 characters and they can um
see the intention and the experience
that sits behind it and that's why i
love having these conversations but
that's why i love talking to you i can
talk to you forever because i it's like
i know how many books you've read tom
and your ability to have condensed the
sort of key part of the wisdom in so
many things in those books but also in
your own life through self-awareness is
the most amazing thing ever
i'm going to say this because i feel
like people need to get the roses
sometimes there's a lot of people in the
self-awareness game there's a lot of
sort of the self-sort of development
content um personal development space
however you want to define it you are by
far
the
best in my view based on what i think
matters someone that has immense
knowledge is able to deliver it but in a
way that's engaging and wrapped in
storytelling
and then maybe the fifth is just this
humility and this honesty so i've said
this to my friends privately when they
say what's this guy like what's this guy
i gotta know tom's the best tom is the
best
and whether you realize that or not
whether it matters or not is there it
doesn't matter but for me you are and
you're the guy when you know a video
pops up or if it's you and lisa making a
video together i'm like
i don't i don't necessarily need to
understand the subject matter but i know
the guy and his thinking and his
intention and i know the way his brain
thinks so
i'm going to get a ton of value from
this i'm just telling you to your face
because i say it behind your back that's
so extraordinary no it's true it's what
i say behind your back so um and i i was
perplexed when i first met you at your
house and four years ago and i thought
[ __ ] how it's funny because it makes
me realize how much i i can improve in
the most positive way
you know in terms of my delivery in
terms of my ideas and my thinking and my
storytelling it's really made me like
inspired by by how much i the space i
have to grow um
so thank you thank you for giving me
your time today i know you're incredibly
busy person man thank you for one of the
most fun interviews i've ever done this
is a lot of fun no it really was it was
awesome
i had a few words to say about one of my
sponsors on this podcast as the seasons
have begun to change so has my diet and
um
right now i'm going to be completely
honest with you i'm starting to think a
lot about
slimming down a little bit because over
the last couple of probably the last
four or five months my diet has been
pretty bad um and it started to show a
little bit really over the last two
months i go to the gym about 80 percent
of the time so i track it with 10 of my
friends in a whatsapp group and this
tracker online that we all use together
and so one of the things i'm doing now
to reduce my calorie intake and trying
to get back to being nutritionally
complete and all i eat is i'm having the
heel protein shake thank you hill for
making a product that i actually like
the salted caramel is my favorite i've
got the banana one here which is the one
my girlfriend likes but for me salted
caramel is
the one
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]